Spider-Man: Far From Home hasn't yet swung
onto theater screens for most fans to see,
but the long-awaited Spidey sequel premiered
in Hollywood for industry insiders and critics
on June 26.
The following day, Marvel lifted its embargo
on Far From Home reviews, and outlets wasted
no time publishing critics' initial reactions.
As of noon Eastern on the day the embargo
lifted, Far From Home shined bright with a
92 percent approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
That's well above the threshold needed for
a "Certified Fresh" distinction.
For the most part, critics are gushing about
Spider-Man: Far From Home, particularly for
its quote, "breezily unpredictable blend of
teen romance and superhero action," as Rotten
Tomatoes itself summarizes it.
Reviewers also love that Far From Home, quote,
"stylishly sets the stage for the next era
of the MCU" by introducing characters including
Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio.
Danielle Solzman of Solzy at the Movies gave
the film 4.5 stars out of 5, writing that
it:
"...deals with the Avengers: Endgame fallout
in a way that only this film can [and is]
able to close the chapter on one book while
laying the foundation for another."
GamesRadar critic Jordan Farley called Far
From Home:
"...another home run for the MCU that puts
Pete's responsibilities in a post-Iron Man
world front and centre during a rib-tickling
summer romance [...] Whatever you do, don't
skip the credits."
Writing for Mashable, Alexis Nedd noted that
the Spider-Man sequel wonderfully follows
up Avengers: Endgame and paves the way for
Holland's Peter Parker to play an even bigger
role in the MCU as Phase 4 begins:
"Far From Home doesn't waste an iota of the
good will Marvel has earned in its previous
offerings every cheeky nod towards Peter's
future in the MCU feels genuine […] Even
though the next phase is still shrouded in
mystery, Spider-Man: Far From Home does a
fantastic job of latching the door that Endgame
closed, while opening a whole new universe
of possibilities for Marvel."
Like Farley, Nedd touted the importance of
the post-credits scenes.
The Wrap's Alonso Duralde noted that Far From
Home is, quote, "an entertaining example of
what we used to call 'a summer movie'" thanks
to its playful romance between Peter Parker
and MJ...
"I'm messing with you.
Thank you."
"You're welcome."
"You look pretty, too."
...as well as Aunt May and Happy Hogan.
Duralde adds that
"[It has] stakes that are about personal growth
rather than intergalactic armageddon, and
some satisfying hero-on-villain throwdowns."
David Crow at Den of Geek brought up director
Sam Raimi's original Spider-Man trilogy in
his review of Far From Home, writing that
the flick is
"...accepting of Raimi's legacy and incorporates
some of that high-flying iconography instead
of running from it."
He also gave kudos to Gyllenhaal, whom he
felt played Mysterio with, quote, "wide-eyed
intensity."
"There's art of me that wants me to tell ya
to just turn around and run away from all
this.
And then there's another part of me that knows
what we're about to fight."
At Forbes, Scott Mendelson wrote that Far
From Home is a, quote, "robust improvement"
upon Homecoming:
"At the very least, the film presents a Peter
Parker who is relatively good at his job and
doesn't consistently screw up to the point
where you wish he'd hang up the costume before
he kills someone [...] That was my biggest
gripe with Homecoming, as the film's 'Peter
has to learn to be a hero worthy of the Avengers'
shtick turned him into an MCU variation on
Curious George.
[...] Far From Home offers more of what worked
last time and less of what didn't."
Not everyone felt the same way, though, as
a common criticism of Far From Home is that
it isn't as sleek as Homecoming, despite being
entertaining in its own right.
USA Today's Brian Truitt was one such critic,
writing:
"Far From Home has a lot more boxes to check
than Homecoming in terms of storytelling,
and while it's always enjoyable, the film
feels unfocused in parts.
Everything changes when a major turn happens
of the story-exploding, can't-talk-about-it-at-all
variety and the last half takes on a very
meta vibe with some of the craziest visuals
Marvel has unleashed in a while and a stellar
understanding of what Gyllenhaal can do so
well on screen."
Spider-Man: Far From Home has pulled in some
sour reviews to go alongside the stellar ones.
"I'm sorry."
"Sorry doesn't cut it."
"I understand.
I just wanted to be like you."
"And I wanted you to be better."
Todd McCarthy at The Hollywood Reporter called
the film "bumpy," with, quote, "hokey and
ill-judged" special effects, "ill-motivated
and less-than-awesome action set-pieces,"
and a villain that isn't compelling enough.
The New York Post's Johnny Oleksinski said
that Far From Home's action and logic, quote,
"fall short of its awesome predecessor," while
Pamella Powell of Reel Honest Reviews kept
things simple when she called the sequel,
quote, "just another formulaic super hero
film."
Even so, the general consensus is that the
flick is impressively charming, fun, funny,
and totally rad.
Judge for yourselves when Spider-Man: Far
From Home hits theaters July 2.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.